nous sommes le lundi 27 avril 2015
bonsoir et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
journal de la rédaction voici les
principaux titres qui seront développés
au cours de la prochaine demi heure
après un nouveau scrutin municipal
alexandra rosetti udi a retrouvé son
fauteuil de maire une victoire nette qui
ne devrait pas entraîner de nouveau
recours devant le conseil d'état
voisins-le-bretonneux la première
station autolib des yvelines en service
au chesnay sept véhicules disponibles 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 et puis
nous reviendrons sur la journée
nationale de la déportation c'était hier
dimanche à cette occasion le président
hollande a rappelé que le pire pouvait
toujours se produire le témoignage en
plateau de francine christophe arrêté à
huit ans et demi puis déportée en 1944 à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui une
signature à très symbolique c'est et à
cet après midi il s'agissait d'un
parrainage civil pour soutenir keshav un
lycéen originaire de l'île maurice qui a
reçu le 7 février dernier une obligation
de quitter le territoire français
applicable depuis le 8 mars keshav est
arrivé en france il ya un peu plus d'un
an pour rejoindre la famille de sa mère
il est scolarisé au lycée jean-perrin de
saint-cyr-l'ecole en terminale bac pro
commerce
une mobilisation s'est rapidement mise
en place dans son établissement scolaire
relayé à par réseau éducation sans
frontières rsf
un recours a été déposé devant le
tribunal administratif en attente de son
examen
rsf a pour la première fois pour cette
année 2015 a organisé un parrainage
civil action est symbolique sans valeur
juridique mais qui permet à keshav ce
jeune lycéen d'être soutenus par des
élus de la république
alexandrine nancy conseillère municipale
aux clayes-sous-bois et benoît hamon
ancien ministre actuel député des
yvelines écouter dans le texte de la
circulaire qui avait été
passé comme manuel valls était ministre
de l'intérieur il y avait la
recommandation faite aux services de
l'état de prendre en compte la situation
de ces jeunes scolarisés parfaitement
intégré à la vie de leur territoire
c'est le cas pour les chefs daraya et
j'ai accepté de le parrainer pour cette
raison là parce que je pense que il est
légitime qu'ils puissent être
régularisés avoir derrière les papiers
et qu'il permette le passé son bac dans
de bonnes conditions mais je vais en
profiter pour saluer le travail
remarquable de réseau éducation sans
frontières parce qu'elles permettent de
rappeler que derrière les chiffres il ya
des individus qui je rappelle que
raccompagnait quelqu'un ça coûte à peu
près trente mille euros que ces
politiques qui visent à ramener sur l'or
dans leurs pays d'origine des étrangers
en situation irrégulière ça coûte aussi
l'argent la république donc quand on
peut retrouver une solution ici pour
quelqu'un qui le mérite et dans le cas
de l'application du droit
non seulement ça réduit la dépense
publique en plus ça permet de soulager
une famille un jeune et souvent en bien
plus alice est tout entier comme ce sera
le cas à saint cyr l'école
propos recueillis par catherine mulato 4
millions d'euros c'est le montant de la
fraude et du préjudice subi par l'urssaf
des yvelines grâce à des sociétés
fantômes des chèques et des fausses
factures a un fils et son père ont mis
en place un système leur permettant en
un peu moins de deux ans de détourner
des fonds de collecte de cet organisme
de collecte de l'organisation des
cotisations salariales et patronales le
plus jeune a été interpellé le second
suspect est toujours recherché il serait
installé en turquie plusieurs sociétés
du département sont également suspectés
d'avoir participé à cette arnaque
la journée nationale du souvenir de la
déportation instauré par la loi du 14
avril 1954 se déroule chaque année lors
du dernier dimanche d'avril cette année
à l'occasion de la 70e cérémonie de
libération des camps le premier ministre
a appelé depuis le mémorial parisien
dédié aux martyrs à poursuivre le combat
contre une barbarie qui peut changer de
visage ce sont ses propres termes le
président françois hollande depuis le
camp de struthof en alsace à lui déclaré
que le pire pouvait toujours se produire
invité du journal ce soir francine
christophe mon soir
et bienvenue sur ce plateau vous avez
été arrêté à l'âge de 8 ans et demi
26 juillet 1942 avec votre mère en
tentant de passer la ligne de
démarcation puis toutes les deux à
déporter le 2 mai 1944 avant d'écouter
votre témoignage vous propose de partir
pour guyancourt où se tenait hier matin
également une cérémonie commémorative la
marseillaise retentissait dimanche matin
à guyancourt
une vingtaine de personnes sont venues
rendre hommage aux victimes
les déportations de la seconde guerre
mondiale par ul le maire adjoint une
dizaine d'anciens combattants il calcule
bien pour toi un travail de mémoire
important à perpétuer auprès des plus
jeunes
depuis 30 ans j'étais revient dans les
trois collèges débit en cours au niveau
des troisièmes pour expliquer ce qu'est
a été la résistance en france pour
expliquer les conditions de vie de la
population pour rappeler la barbarie
allemande parce que barbarie il y avait
donc je fais ce travail depuis 30 ans
alors je pense que ce rôle que je joue
est très utile et que tant que je
pourrai le faire je continuerai de le
faire interventions dans les collèges ou
encore commémorations sont autant
d'occasions pour rappeler à la
population les conséquences dramatiques
des idéologies racistes
une histoire que l'on pourrait penser
lointaine mais qui pourtant occupe
l'actualité et inquiète les esprits
assez important pour le devoir de
mémoire ce qui est même dommage c'est
qu'il ya la limite on communique pas
assez puisque on est oui on n'est pas
très nombreux et un moment donné c'est
vrai que si on pouvait y intéresser la
population notamment les enfants les
jeunes bon c'est vrai que ces quelques
jours avant la journée du 8 mai mais
c'est vrai que ça serait intéressant de
le rappeler à tous surtout au vu de
l'actualité récente qu'on arras est
toujours très important discuter de
l'actualité internationale
on sent monter de nouveau les mêmes les
mêmes slogans racistes xénophobes
antisémites pour et on sent que ça monte
ça monte ça monte et moi je dis on peut
être inquiet je suis inquiet et je pense
qu'il a beaucoup d'autres qui sont
inquiets avec moi et je vais essayer de
faire comprendre aux jeunes qu'il faut
qu'il fasse très attention si on fait
pas attention on risque de voir revenir
des extrêmes comment alors que ce soit
religieux ou politique
on en est à associer les jeunes à cette
prise de conscience c'est toute la
volonté de la ville de guyancourt qui
fera participer à la prochaine
commémoration du 8 mai trois classes de
scolaires et de classes de collégiens
sujet de cette période qui a connu la
déportation comment vous avez vécu ce
moment de commémoration hier à travers
la france c'est un moment difficile qui
rouvre des blessures mais malgré tout
nécessaire
non je ne pense pas que la route est
longue blessure c'est un très beau
moment au contraire qui nous apporte une
certaine paix le fait que ça soit
reconnue c'est tellement formidable
c'est venu tardivement et maintenant je
crois que c'est bien entrer dans les
têtes qu'il faut pas oublier ça je dis
exactement ce que ce monsieur à lunettes
là vient de dire si on ne le dit pas ça
peut revenir mais lorsque vous entendez
le président justement de la république
déclare et l'antisémitisme et le racisme
sont encore là vous vous dites que
malgré les commémorations malgré les
témoignages que vous portez pas la seule
mais que vous portez également il ya
toujours en danger
il a toujours un danger ça se fait mal
je rappelle toujours que hitler a dit le
génocide des arméniens qui s'en souvient
on en parle maintenant mais il a fallu
du temps
donc on oublie tout ça et il ne faut pas
il est le week end une nouvelle
agression d'un homme de 53 ans était à
saint thois en sortant de la synagogue
il a été roué de coups traiter également
de sale juif
vous vous dites que c'est un acte isolé
ou qu'il ya matière à être inquiet
aujourd'hui on entendu dans le reportage
une personne un déporté également qui
témoigne un ancien combattant qui disait
voilà aujourd'hui moi je suis inquiet je
le suis aussi
je suis inquiète et il m'arrive d'avoir
un peu
r j'ai eu peur toute mon enfance un bien
entendu et même temps de l'adolescence
après j'avais encore peur c'était en moi
et maintenant il m'arrive de temps en
temps avoir un peu peur ça c'est bien
ennuyeux vous résidez dans les yvelines
vous témoignent régulièrement devant les
plus jeunes dans les écoles pour
raconter votre histoire on va en parler
plus en détail tout à l'heure vous
écrivez également une petite fille
privilégié et c'est un souvenir grillage
il ya eu la fête inconnu également vous
avez rédigé vous raconter cette histoire
depuis longtemps les réactions sont
toujours les mêmes lorsque vous parlez
de votre histoire au public même par
rapport aux enfants est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le message est moins fort
et un détachement de votre auditoire ou
pas non c'est juste le contraire
c'est tout à fait ça c'est paradoxal
parce que toujours ce oui ce sont des
vraies études et taxes non c'est juste
le comtal les enfants sont extrêmement
intéressé il faut même des travaux sur
ce qu'on leur raconte des travaux par
écrit qu'ils sont exceptionnelles et mon
premier livre une petite fille
privilégiés qui est un témoignage que
qui est sorti en 95 mais peut-être
quinze ou vingt établissements scolaires
en france qu'ils ont monté une pièce de
théâtre un curieux ça veut dire qu'il ya
matière aussi à être rassuré même si
vous êtes inquiète aujourd'hui vous
n'êtes pas la seule source il est de ces
actes on peut se dire que les plus
jeunes générations il faut rester voilà
optimiste il ya autre chose c'est que
notre époque par télévision y avait pas
les ong y est pas tous ces gens là ne
veut pas les gens comme vous vous pouvez
toujours dénoncer ça n'existait pas
cette histoire une petite fille
privilégiés qui sera jouée en pièce de
théâtre justement le 29 mai à 20 heures
pour le grand public 14 heures pour les
écoles avec des débats à chaque fois
qu'ils suivront voir cette histoire
aussi sur scène votre histoire reprendre
vie comment vous vous l'avez vécu
comment vous le vivez comment ça se
passe de voir aujourd'hui maintenant sur
scène joue et ce avec beaucoup de joie
et en même temps beaucoup de souffrance
c'est comment je vois l'actrice sur la
scène qui disent que j'ai écrit il
m'arrive d'être totalement détaché de me
dire c'est vraiment moi qui écris ça
c'est vraiment moi qui ai vécu sa
maladie mal à croire que nous ayons vécu
ça on comprend pas pourquoi on est là
d'ailleurs vous avez qu'à des syriens
l'écriture justement de
l'ami de l'adaptation n'a pour la pièce
de théâtre c'était pas une adaptation on
a pris directement le livre en faisant
des coupures
c'est tout votre histoire justement
votre père est prisonnier de guerre en
allemagne lorsque vous êtes arrêté à
huit ans et demi 26 juillet 42 avec
votre mère c'est en garde rochefoucauld
en charente vous vouliez atteindre la
zone libre comment s'est passé ce moment
justement cette arrestation
cette arrestation a été fort dur parce
que j'ai 8 ans et demi et nous avons les
faux papiers nous avons un passeur qui
viennent le faire passer la ligne
mais est-ce que les faux papiers sont
mal faits ce que nous avons si peur que
ça soit dans nos yeux je ne sais pas
mais on nous emmène maman et moi la
kommandantur et on a commencé par nous
c'est pareil et moi on m'a mise dans une
pièce avec un soldat remet un gros chien
je rappelle que les tous les déportés
ont peur des chiens avec des chiens
tellement dressée comme des fauves et
puis j'entends maman dans l'autre pièce
qu'on commence à interroger et
j'expliquais longtemps qu'elle crie non
non non je ne suis pas juive non elle
m'avait dit tu sais fait très attention
si tu avoues tu seras mise en prison et
j'ai tenu le coup pendant un bon moment
malgré les insultes mais habitants et
demi c'est difficile et puis on a fini
par dire à maman que si elle n'avait pas
m'emmener donc elle est internée dans
plusieurs camps ont finalement déportée
en 1944 à bergen belsen
on va voir des images d'ailleurs comme
été tournée lors de la libération de ce
conte comment ça s'est passé cette
arrivée là bas dans ce camp en 1944
j'avais déjà souffert en france puisque
j'avais déjà de prison et cinq ans mais
ce que j'ai découvert à berriane nagel
évidemment c'était un peu différent et
c'était un énorme choc mais en même
temps comme j'étais une enfant déjà
habitué à beaucoup de souffrance je les
moins gelé plus avec moins d'affolement
que ma mère ma mère c'est des russes que
je suis là ce que je vais en tirer ma
fille moi pas moi je suis devenu un
animal qui ne pensait plus qu'à une
chose manger un animal justement
j'aimerais que vous me donniez ce
témoignage parce que vous l'avez déjà
livré lors du 1 au président françois
hollande c'était lors d'une rencontre
mémorial de la shoah au début de cette
année
anecdote on va dire ça comme ça lors de
la libération lorsque vous arrivez en
france donc on vous tend une orange
s'est salement il ya une dame de la
croix rouge d'abord la porte du wagon
sourire les gens font à une enfant
évidemment il n'y a pas d'enfants qu'ils
soient revenues si peu de poignet qui
soient revenues des camps
lui l'enfant et il ya une dame de la
croix rouge qui s'approche qui me tend
une bleue pour toi et je lui dis mais
qu'est ce que c'est mais c'est une range
c'est pour toi tu la manges
mais comment ça se mange et ben tu vas
les peluches et si je ne travaillais
plus sûr et puis qu'il va manger le
fruit l'intérieur bien madame je vais
faire comme vous dites je vous remercie
mais les épluchures ne jetterai pas
parce que j'ai bien sûr qu'il ya un
camarade qui se raconte anglais manger
lui il a fallu tout réapprendre après
réapprendre à être une enfant et
apprendre à vivre même s'il y avait une
fourchette même savoir nouer ses lacets
tout juste parce qu'on l'a pas précisé
pour le titre de ce premier recueil que
vous avez publié et qui aujourd'hui
adapté en pièce de théâtre que vous
pourrez découvrir du côté du prisme le
29 mai et il encourt une petite fille
privilégiées oui on m'a souvent réglés
si c'était ironique ça ne l'est pas du
tout je suis privilégié je suis en vie
des gens quel privilège pour un enfant
et puis j'ai un autre prix ville agisse
ordinaire c'est que j'ai retrouvé papa
et maman
les deux ans réalise enfin pendant la
guerre ce qui était caché car il ya eu
des la france entière dans la france en
tirent il ya eu ce qu'on appelle des
justes maintenant des gens qui ont caché
des enfants mais c'est enfin le tour de
pas leurs parents alors que moi j'ai
retrouvé les deux alors quel privilège
vous dans 5 sans aucune ironie vous vous
estimez aujourd'hui privilégiée à huy
une dernière question parler des
commémorations tout à l'heure vous êtes
retourné sur ce camp de bergen-belsen
bien sûr j'y vais tous les ans et givet
la semaine prochaine c'est presque un
besoin
je suis chez moi quand je marche
mais quand je m'assois par terre je
touche c'est un morceau de ma vie de mon
enfance que j'ai laissé là je suis chez
moi vous êtes vous êtes chez vous vous
êtes détacher de la souffrance que vous
avez pu avoir
oui je suis détaché de cette souffrance
je retrouve une petite fille
alors après je passe devant les
monticules sous les monticules je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de morts
je les salue je suis pas folle mais j'ai
besoin de leur dire salut les morts je
ne vous oublie pas parce que si je les
oubliés jeux lectures à une deuxième
fois
merci francine christophe da est revenu
sur ce pouvoir témoigner je rappelle que
vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs ouvrages
dont une petite fille privilégiés dont
on vient de parler et qui sera portée au
théâtre / elancourt au prisme le 29 mai
14h représentations pour les scolaires
suivie d'un débat et vous serez présente
et vous serez aussi présentes le soir
pour la représentation grand public à
20h merci à vous encore même si énorme
nous reprenons le cours de ce journal à
présent le réseau sortir du nucléaire a
organisé une marche samedi dernier pour
commémorer le 29e anniversaire de
l'accident de la centrale de tchernobyl
en ukraine une cinquantaine de personnes
mobilisées pour dénoncer l usage du
nucléaire civil militaire le réseau
milite depuis une dizaine d'années pour
l'utilisation d'énergies propres les
précisions au micro de william l le
message si vous le temps c'est le
nucléaire est dangereux
quelle que soit sa nature que soient
civils ou militaires aussi bien pour
charbon d'ailleurs que pour le pétrole
ou que pour l'uranium les ressources
terrienne sont finis a abandonné bien il
faut bien aussi savoir que dans tous les
cas de figure il va y avoir une pénurie
qui est annoncé il faut engager
effectivement la construction de deux
centrales non non nucléaires et nos
productive de
de co2 comme le solaire comme
l'hydrolien temps comme ça de manière à
pouvoir fermer les centrales le plus
rapidement possible on ne veut pas faire
le dur immédiate mais de programmer la
transition pour pour aller fermer le
plus rapidement possible politique
alexandra rose et il retrouve donc son
fauteuil de maire à l'issue du conseil
d'installation de ce samedi à voisins le
bretonneux alexandra rosetti dont la
liste est arrivée en tête à l'issue du
second tour de l'élection municipale
partielle a été élu donc sans surprise
par ses pairs catherine mulato et
yolaine torres beaucoup de monde ce
samedi matin en mairie de
voisins-le-bretonneux pour assister au
conseil municipal d'installation avec
sandra rosetti vinci voir candidat
numéro 2 j'arrache trois voies sans
surprise alexandre rosetti dont la liste
était arrivée en tête du second tour de
l'élection municipale partielle était
lui même je pense qu'elle a fait du bon
travail pour 90 donc y avait pas de
raison qu'elle soit pas réélu chance
l'équipe qu'il a été mise en place il ya
un an il fallait qu'elle prenne ses
marques les appris ce qui s'est passé là
c'est vraiment dommage je trouve que
deux mois de perdus c'est beaucoup pour
moi il n'y a pas eu de changements réels
en fait
à la limite je remercie monsieur biette
d'avoir fait re les armes
alexandra arditi et on le souhaiter de
tout coeur voilà des faits je suis très
ému là je suis très ému c'était une
belle matinée les services nous ont fait
magnifique décoration très belle très
belle surprise enfin voila c on sent que
c'est une vraie fête républicaine voilà
très ému effectivement au moment de
recevoir les sharks de premier magistrat
alexandra rosetti c'est que le temps
presse entre l'annulation de l'élection
et le nouveau ce que tu ailles s'est
écoulé deux mois et il y à faire
terminer l'évaluation sur les rythmes
scolaires relancer les appels d'offres
pour les travaux dans l'école a mené cet
été et poursuivre la concertation sur le
plan local d'urbanisme intercommunal bon
de moi c'est rattrapable d'autant plus
que les élus sont tous réinstaller dans
les fonctions qu'il occupait
précédemment dans leur délégation
donc ils peuvent reprendre le travail
très rapidement la mary des il peut
s'appuyer sur les 26 élus de son équipe
ces deux de plus par rapport à mars 2014
jean h élus divers gauche dispose de
trois élus thierry gastaud et olivia
fond saut de deux élus chacun les
oppositions se veulent constructives
on n'est pas là pour s'opposer
systématiquement on est là pour
travailler avec la majorité avec
alexandra rosetti et son équipe et on
n'a pas du tout d'esprit partisan
simplement on veut agir pour lévis il
ment dans une action constructive dans
le sens de l'intérêt général je pense
qu'on est tous rapports présentés de
lévis in one intérêt d ici noir et en
même temps être vigilant par rapport aux
actions menées par la majorité
c'est à la fois troublant émouvant enfin
je suis un républicain donc ça fait
forcément quelque chose j'y vais avec un
climat très très détendu très
constructive les dossiers à traiter
devraient être nombreux lors du prochain
conseil municipal prévu le 5 mai
un mois du chômage les derniers chiffres
ont été publiés le nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi en catégorie a sans aucune
activité augmente de 0,4 pour cent pour
ce mois de mars au niveau national bien
sûr la première station autolib du
département maintenant et en service du
côté du chesnay une station pilote près
de la mairie qui gère le dispositif de
sept véhicules électriques disponibles 7
jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 d'autres
stations vont voir le jour dans la
commune d'ici au 12 juin l'autonomie de
ces voitures est de 160 km vitesse un
maximum 110 km heure ce qui permettra de
réaliser donc aisément des allers
retours vers paris le coût 9 euros la
demi-heure sans abonnement 5,5 euros si
vous souscrivez à un abonnement annuel
de 120 euros que pensez vous de ce
nouveau service pourriez-vous être amené
à l'utiliser c'est notre question du
jour vos réponses ben je suis contre
pourquoi moi pourquoi parce qu'on a
suffisamment de voitures comme ça en
banlieue et bon bah on va encore payer
ça dans nos impôts alors moi j'ai déjà
un véhicule électrique donc du coup je
me posais une question si je peux
utiliser les bornes donc je pense que je
m'y intéresser ah bah oui complètement
oui bah pour me rendre sur paris ce que
j'ai souvent pas mal de soirées jeux
travers l'agent de voyages vais juste en
bas dans des soirées de boulot donc
voilà souvent on objecter les parkings
donc bon ben je pense que c'est pas mal
je m'en servirai certainement pas mais
ça ne gène pas assez bien peut-être ça
rendra service je ne sais pas donc pas
du tout moi j'ai un véhicule puis je
suis amené à me déplacer beaucoup chez
les clients donc non tout à fait je
trouve ça extra les petits déplacements
c'est une petite voiture donc ça se
garent n'importe où et puis je trouve
que c'est pratique et ce surtout
économique au niveau de l'hygiène
cette d'électricité quand même donc
c'est très écolo loisirs les vacances
scolaires continue pour occuper vos
enfants la maison de l'environnement
c'est à magny les hameaux propose divers
ateliers sur le thème du faire soi même
cette fois ci il était question de
couture mathilde qu'à berne patrick
jacques de dixmude s'y sont essayés
port-lay rabat boutonnière ses enfants
après le b à ba de la couture de
l'invention à la fabrication la maison
de l'environnement vogue sur le thème du
faire soi même
dans s'est rendu compte que finalement
dans tout ce dont on avait besoin de
faire au quotidien que ce soit du
bricolage ou de la couture on fait le
béaba reconnaissait plus journal oublié
et c'était finalement une grande demande
avec des choses simples vous savez pu
les faire et donc finalement dans une
approche des douilles sur scène c'est à
dire de réapprendre à refaire des choses
simples on a envie d'initier à la
couture comme on peut initier au
bricolage à la réparation des objets et
à l'invention et la création en france
des parents retroussent leurs manches et
sortent les dés à coudre pour les aider
une professionnelle de la couture les
accompagnent l'objet du jour un petit
sac pour tous j'allais souvent un objet
facile à faire et pas trop tu prends pas
trop de temps parce qu'on a vécu leurs
aînés pour pouvoir parce que faut
compter pour un objet s'est rapidement
fait pour pour que ça leur plaise et
donc là on nous avons fait voilà la
petite pochette de donner à l'asticot
avec un petit ruban pour mettre ses
affaires dedans on sait tout simple
c'est un retour aux bases qui connaît un
succès une quinzaine d'enfants se sont
plongés dans la confection de leur
propre sac un peu de concentration et de
savoir faire et le tour est joué
c'est le point piqué et là c'est le
point de relais bas celui là il permet
deux assemblées de deux partis ensemble
et cela permet de faire alors les belges
vous connaissent un peu parce que ça
permet de changer de machine et je
trouve que ça mais c'est de mobiliser
des doigts ça rendait doit plus habiles
la maison de l'environnement clos son
cycle du do it yourself prochaine
thématique le recyclage du sport
maintenant pour terminer cette édition
handball la team 78 organisé ce week-end
son tournoi d'auch palais des sports à
elles ont cours au gymnase de la malle
menottes à maurepas et au gymnase mont
boron à versailles trois sites
l équipe a terminé la deuxième place de
ce rendez-vous résumé de ces deux jours
de compétition avec michael et demi
d'euros et yolaine torres
un grand tournoi de handball moins de 18
ans était organisée ce week-end dans les
gymnases d'elancourt 2 mort paille de
versailles huit équipes de la région ile
de france ont fait le déplacement pour
participer à la compétition
parmi les favoris on retrouve boulogne
billancourt pontault combault et la team
78 l'équipe locale le niveau est très
relevé c'est une des équipes qui jouent
le haut de tableau en national
ce bon ils ont des bons joueurs il en a
yo ma et son centre de formation et un
ace en équipe de france
quatrième de la poule 4 du championnat
de france l'entraîneur de la team 78
veut avant tout faire progresser son
groupe pendant ce tournoi face à de
redoutables adversaires
ça sert à rien d'expérience avoir des
matches durs à apprendre à les gagner
apprendre à rester motivés et concentrés
sur les matches qui sont touche touche
comme on a une loi on gagne d'un match
d'un but on perd nos deux matches d'un
but et l'autre en fait il fallait qu'on
gagne 2,6 pour gagner et on gagne plus
de 6 donc c'était comme c'était un match
serré parce qu'il fallait avoir le blues
pensif
après une phase de plus convaincante et
un bilan de deux victoires en trois
matches la team 78 hisse en finale
l'équipe va défier l'ogre créteil
l'épouvantail du tournoi un match
compliqué que l'entraîneur a préparé
tactiquement où tous ont commencé fort
tout de suite première à pâques on la
construit après on enchaîne on défend et
on joue mon mba l'on peut défense et de
montées de balle reprise dépendait de
l'engagement d'accord égard pour leurs
matchs ou encore le discours d'
alexandre taillefer a porté ses fruits
dans le premier acte la team soit 118
fait jeu égal avec créteil et qui perd
seulement de deux buts à la mi temps
mais au retour des vestiaires le rouleau
compresseur créteil se met en marche
score final 25 19 on était fatigués ont
manqué de rotations et puis au bout d'un
moment c'est l'échec sur les tirs du
gardien adverse qui a donc remporté le
trophée du meilleur gardien qui nous a
fait mal notamment sur des sur des
contre attaques
les trois premiers matchs ils ont été
bons on a bien joué
reste et on est resté pareil sur tous
les matches après celui là on la
première mi temps on accroche et la
deuxième mi temps on décroche parce que
physiquement c'est plus compliqué c'est
une équipe qui sera sûrement championne
de france cette année qui l'a été
l'année dernière
donc c'est un bon résultat contre
créteil pendant ces deux jours de
compétition la team 78 a pu montrer sa
combativité
une qualité qui sera indispensable 9 mai
pour venir à bout de tremblay en
huitièmes de finale du championnat de
france
en attendant l'équipe peut savourer sa
très belle deuxième place dans ce
tournoi l essentiel du sport justement
c'est tout de suite sur télé fil avec
michael et me d'euros le 7 8 sport comme
chaque lundi le journal revient demain
mardi au même horaire excellente soirée